vampire hunters immortal warriors a zack
snyder space epic 2022 and beyond is
going to be mind-blowing which movies
are you most excited for
a good slasher franchise never really
dies and in 2022 scream is going to
prove it the much anticipated fifth film
in the franchise marks the beginning of
a new era for the series being the first
installment made without the involvement
of director wes craven who passed away
in 2015 but that doesn't mean the film
will be without any familiar faces
original scream stars nev campbell
courtney cox and david arquette have all
signed on to reprise their characters
promising a major reunion for the
characters who have managed to survive
ever since the first film debuted in
1996 considering the presence of those
original cast members everyone knew they
could expect more of a sequel than a
reboot with scream but the first trailer
for the film actually offered an
intriguing hybrid of both in the trailer
sydney and company learned that a new
killer has done the iconic ghostface
costume to terrorize the town of
woodsboro echoing what they experienced
25 years ago a new group of teenagers is
in peril this time though and sydney and
her friends might be the key to their
survival directed by ready or not matt
better nelly open and tyler gillette
scream is scheduled to arrive in
theaters on january 14th 2022
in 2012 director scott derekson and
screenwriter c robert cargill released
their first collaboration sinister a
film still widely viewed as one of the
best original horror stories to emerge
from the 2010s now after shifting focus
to work on projects such as doctor
strange the duo are headed back to their
horror roots with the black phone
another terrifying film with a very
creepy premise the black phone is an
adaptation of the short story of the
same name written by joe hill author of
books such as horns and co-creator of
the hit comic lock and key it tells the
story of a teenage boy who's abducted
and locked in a basement by a serial
killer though no one can hear him down
in the killer's lair the boy finds that
he can hear something through a
seemingly disconnected telephone kept in
the room the voices of the killers are
the victims gone but still somehow
speaking through this mysterious black
phone derekson and cargill announced
their involvement in the project in
october 2020. more recently blumhouse
productions and universal pictures have
announced that the black foam will land
in theaters february 4th 2022
with films like independence day and the
day after tomorrow director roland
emmerich helped to find the modern
action blockbuster as we know he's a
master when it comes to making
entertaining films with truly bonkers
premises and in 2022 he'll try to do it
again with moonfall the film will follow
a crew of misfits as they attempt a
desperate mission to venture out into
space and prevent the moon from
colliding with the earth so it's a
particularly apt roland emmerich premise
and the first footage for the film
revealed we're getting exactly what it
says on the tin that is the moon falling
out of the sky and a bunch of scientists
trying to figure out a way to save the
world joining gamerick for this wild
ride is an all-star cast led by halle
berry patrick wilson and john bradley
though it went through a pretty wild
pre-production ride due to the pandemic
the film is now on track for a release
date of february 4th 2022
with this 2015 directorial debut the
witch director robert eggers established
himself as one of the most intriguing
horror directors around he only cemented
that reputation in 2019 with the
lighthouse an even stranger journey into
darkness that stunned the critics and
weirded out general audiences everywhere
that neptune stretchy dead windslow
with two films under his belt edgar's
next project is the northmen yet another
historical film that will feature an
epic scope unlike anything he's directed
previously a story of the legendary
scandinavian prince amlath the film will
allow eggers to exercise his detailed
approach to period filmmaking while
working with his biggest all-star cast
yet so who's set to star in the title
role eggers has landed the very
appropriate alexander skarsgard and the
northman will also reunite the filmmaker
with his witch star anya taylor joy
after filming amid pandemic conditions
in 2020 the northman is now set for
release on april 22nd 2022
in the spring of 2022 just over five
years after his mcu debut doctor strange
will finally get his very first sequel
marvel studios announced that san diego
comic con that director scott derekson
and star benedict cumberbatch would both
return for doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness which derekson
promised would be the first truly scary
film in the mcu however derekson vacated
the director's chair due to creative
differences early in 2020 with
spider-man and evil dead legend sam
raimi quickly stepping up to replace him
stranger won't be the only hero in the
flick however he'll be joined by wonder
maximoff the scarlet witch who will be
played once again by elizabeth olsen
wonders appearance in the film will tie
in directly to the events of the disney
plus series wonder vision they'll also
be joined by much of the original
movie's cast along with newcomer so she
gomez and america chavez doctor strange
and the multiverse of madness hits
theaters may 6 2022
in 2018 the billion dollar transformers
movie franchise got a shake up with
bumblebee a spin-off prequel hybrid that
moved the action to the 1980s and
generated new energy in a franchise
that's been running since 2007. in 2022
the franchise will seek to replicate
that success with transformers rise of
the beasts like bumblebee rise of the
beasts will be a period piece set in
1990s brooklyn and introducing several
new breeds of alien robots to the film
series this time around human characters
played by leads anthony ramos and
dominique fishbach will encounter beast
war characters such as the maximals and
the predacons as an ancient conflict
comes to earth in the form of the
villainous terracons so far we know very
little about the voice cast but peter
cullen is expected to return to the
iconic optimus prime and the legendary
ron pullman will join the franchise as
optimus primal leader of the maximals
transformers rise of the beasts roars
into theaters june 2023
captain marvel was a game changer for
the mcu when it debuted in 2019 it was
the first female-led marvel studios
superhero film one which also managed to
introduce a key alien race to the
universe while expanding another and
setting the stage for more future super
heroines along the way captain marvel 2
was always going to be a big film and
now it's starting to become clear just
how big it will be higher further faster
baby nia de costa is set to direct the
adventure for carol danvers but captain
marvel won't be fighting alone she'll be
joined by tiana paris as monica rambo an
adult version of the child of carol's
best friend from the first film who made
her full debut in one division joining
the two of them will be iman valani as
kamala khan aka miss marvel a captain
marvel super fan son superhero who's
about to debut in her own original
series on disney plus and with these
three together it's no wonder that the
film has been renamed the marvels the
movie is set to hit theaters february
17th 2023
a third guardians of the galaxy film
felt like a foregone conclusion even
before volume 2 hit theaters in the
spring of 2017 but to say the road to
get there has been complicated might be
something of an understatement the film
was originally on track to start
production in 2018 but that changed when
writer director james gunn was fired by
disney over controversial tweets from
years prior gunn was ultimately
reinstated but not before it already
landed a prime gig at warner brothers
writing and directing the suicide squad
still marvel studios agreed to hold on
to the project until gun was ready so
gum went off to make the suicide squad
which then also led to the hbo max
spin-off series peacemaker which further
delayed work on the adventures of the
guardians finally in the spring of 2021
marvel announced that guardians of the
galaxy vol 3 will arrive in theaters may
5th 2023 six years to the day after
volume 2 landed it might feel like a
long way but there will at least be
something in between in december 2020
disney announced that gunn and the
original guardians cast will also
produce the guardians of the galaxy
holiday special set before the third
film which will hit disney plus in
december 2022
with the arrival of disney plus marvel
studios entered a new era one in which
news stories are set to emerge on the
big screen after first taking root on
the small one division for example is
set to continue its tail in some form
via wonder maximoff's appearance in
doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness and while nobody previously knew
what the falcon and the winter soldier
might do to the big picture we now have
a much better idea it's kicking off a
new captain america movie in april 2021
hours after the finale of the falcon and
the winter soldier arrived on disney
plus it was reported that the show's
head writer malcolm spellman is
developing a fourth captain america film
for marvel studios very little is known
about what spellman's film might cover
including exactly who will appear in it
but his work on the disney plus series
left plenty of clues the mcu has a new
captain america for one as well as a
vengeful old cap and john walker a
weapons dealer installed in the u.s
espionage community the winter soldier
still in the big picture and much much
more it's not clear yet when this film
will hit theaters but it's bound to be
worth keeping an eye on during the mcu's
next phase
almost immediately after knives out
became a major mystery hit over the 2019
holiday season writer director ryan
johnson began talking about potential
plans for a sequel those plans took very
solid shape in the spring of 2021 when
netflix signed on to a deal worth
hundreds of millions of dollars that
would set johnson and company up for two
knives out sequel films on the streaming
giant with the backing of netflix and a
lot of goodwill built up from the first
film johnson stepped to work and began
building a predictably stacked cast
while the first knife's out film boasted
an impressive roster of talent only
daniel craig is expected to return from
the first film reprising his role as
private detective benoit blanc it makes
no damn sense
compels me though
the nature of the mystery this time
around remains unclear although it has
been confirmed that at least some of the
film has been shot in greece on top of
that the ensemble johnson is building to
populate the new story it's just as
impressive as that in the original movie
in the first half of 2021 the production
added a ton of major stars to its cast
including dave bautista edward norton
janelle monae catherine hahn leslie odom
jr and kate hudson the knife's out
sequel doesn't have a firm release date
yet but watch out for when it finally
hits netflix it might just be the
all-star mystery to end all other
all-star mysteries
in the summer of 2019 marvel studios
surprised fans everywhere during their
whole h presentation at san diego
comic-con with the reveal that two-time
academy award winner mahershala ali had
been cast as blade in the mcu after
wesley snipes ali will be the second
actor to portray the iconic day walker
vampire hunter in live action and while
it took two years to really get moving
the project is finally starting to take
shape deadline reported in july 2021
that director bassam tariq best known
for the film mogul mowgli has signed on
to helm the upcoming new incarnation of
blade though the studio was reportedly
originally looking for a writer director
to lead the film marvel studios head
kevin feige eventually decided to
separate those duties stacey oseka4 best
known for her work on acclaimed tv
series like hunters and watchmen is set
to write the film's script sadly there's
not much in the way of plot information
about the film just yet nor have marvel
set a firm release date that said the
studio has two talented up-and-comers
working behind the scenes and an
oscar-winning icon set to play a vampire
hunter so no matter when it comes out
this one's bound to be a winner
when birds of prey arrived in 2020 it
seemed to provide a couple of key
ingredients for the future of the dc eu
the first and most obvious was a
continued stepping stone for margot
robbie's harley quinn to grow and
prosper in the universe the second was a
whole new range of scene-stealing
supporting characters who could
presumably spin off into their own films
should the interest be there well it
took a little while but the first of
those potential spin-offs is finally on
the way in august 2021 collider reported
that hbo max is developing a black
canary film starring journey smolit in
the title role returning as a character
after her big screen debut in birds of
prey joining her on the project is misha
green who developed the acclaimed hbo
series lovecraft country in which small
it also starred right now no plot
details have been forthcoming so it's
not clear what the black canary movie
will deal with or where in the dceu
timeline it'll pick up with the
character but the project joins an
ever-growing list of hbo max projects
designed to tie into warner brothers
theatrical releases for dc comics
characters among the other announced
projects the studio is also releasing a
gotham city police drama tied to the
batman a peacemaker series tied to the
suicide squad and a batgirl film that
will reportedly feature the return of
j.k simmons as commissioner jim gordon
in the summer of 2020 netflix released
the old guard a fantasy action film
based on the comic of the same name by
greg rucker and leandro fernandez the
film promptly became one of the biggest
hits the platformers ever seen in a
pandemic stricken world where people
couldn't safely visit movie theaters the
old guard delivered the blockbuster
style action that audiences were craving
at the time and its success paved the
way for a sequel after months of teasing
throughout 2021 netflix finally
confirmed in august that a follow-up to
the film was indeed on the way with a
new director at the helm deadline
reported that victoria mahoney who's
directed episodes of series such as
lovecraft country and helm the second
unit for star wars the rise of skywalker
has signed on to direct the old guard
too the original movie's director gina
prince bythwood announced at the same
time that she elected to step away from
the sequel to focus on other projects
but that she also personally endorsed
mahoney's hire charlize theron and her
old guard co-star kiki lane are both set
to return for the sequel which will be
written by rucker and co-writer david
ellison it does not yet have a firm
release date
after years of working at warner
brothers pictures where he helped build
a whole universe of justice league
heroes zack snyder has moved on to
netflix where he's found a whole new
degree of creative freedom and ambition
the streaming giant launched its first
snyder project the zombie heist film
army of the dead in 2021 and now
snyder's hard at work on his next
netflix original one which will take him
into space
i got a bad feeling about this in august
2021 snyder revealed that his next film
as a director will be rebel moon a
project that originated as a star wars
pitch years ago that he since developed
into a stand-alone sci-fi adventure
inspired by both star wars and his
lifelong love of the films of akira
kurusawa rebel moon will follow the
members of a peaceful space colony as
they gather warriors to help them fight
a tyrannical empire it basically sounds
a bit like 7 samurai in space which has
definitely been done before but it's a
fun premise nonetheless the mummy and
atomic blonde actor sophia boutella is
set to star rebel moon doesn't yet have
a release date but snyder hopes to begin
production sometime in 2022
three decades ago long before the
superhero movie boom kicked off disney
released a rocketeer a period adventure
film about a young high-flying
adventurer battling nazis with a jet bag
he got by way of howard hughes the film
didn't enjoy much of a reception when it
was released in 1991 but time has been
very kind to it and the rocketeer is now
remembered as a classic of its era one
that's long overdue for a sequel in
august 2021 disney revealed that a
sequel is finally on the way with the
return of the rocketeer a disney plus
original film that's set to put the
spotlight on a new version of the iconic
hero the new film which doesn't yet have
a firm release date will be written by
now you see me scream writer ed
reichardt and it will follow a tuskegee
airman who becomes a new rocketeer oscar
nominee david oyalowo is set to produce
the film and may also end up starring at
this point nobody has any idea how long
it will take for the return of the
rocketeer to show up but one thing is
for sure it can't happen soon enough
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one